hey youtubers it's Charlie I just got a
chance to see Jurassic world it was a
ton of fun since most of you probably
haven't seen it yet I'm gonna do a
non-spoilery review first and then I'll
do specific moments with spoilers so
here we go if you guys haven't watched
any of the other Jurassic Park movies in
a while it's been about 14 years since
Jurassic Park 3 that's how long it's
been so the big task of this movie was
to reinvigorate the franchise which I
feel like it did pretty good
you got Chris Pratt who's blowing up all
over the world right now he's like the
next Harrison Ford which is funny
because I did get a bit of an Indiana
Jones vibe off of this character we've
even got the kingpin Vincent D'Onofrio
which is it's kind of funny watching him
do this after doing daredevil they got
Jake Johnson who you pry know from new
girl Kate McGrath you probably remember
from Merlin there's a bunch of familiar
faces there's only one actor from the
previous Jurassic Park films though he
was a geneticist in the first film he's
basically playing the same character he
played in that film pretty pretty much
the entire main cast is knew his
character does a good job of linking
aspects of that first film to this film
is it's almost like they're restarting
the cycle so you see a lot of Easter
eggs for previous films but mostly for
the first film if there's anything that
this film does really well it definitely
captures a lot of the humor and
awkwardness of going to like a giant
theme park just filled with bodies of
people it's so perfect for the disaster
movie genre that's what Jurassic Park
movies are third disaster movies like
san andreas only it's the dinosaurs that
are the earthquake and even though we
have star-lord on screen and a lot of
like really funny performances from the
actors the dinosaurs are still the main
stars of the film it's kind of like
going to a Transformers movie or to like
a ninja turtles movie you don't go to
see Megan Fox you go to see the robots
and the turtles do something just
absolutely crazy that's why this is such
an awesome summer popcorn movie you know
you just go for like a really awesome
rollercoaster ride somatically I think
that's why the Jurassic Park movies
works so well like the way that they
built them because it's a theme park you
go to theme parks to go on rides the
movie itself is kind of like a
rollercoaster ride the a story the film
is all about this dinosaur disaster the
B story lays in a lot of the subtext and
the morality people can be every bit as
bad or even worse than giant man-eating
dinosaurs Steven Spielberg is a director
that's known for like his very visual
storytelling style
and even though he didn't direct this
film there's a lot from his original
Jurassic Park films late into this at
the end of the day though Jurassic Park
is a franchise so Jurassic world this
movie is not gonna be the last one by it
by any means like I said they're trying
to reinvigorate the franchise there are
a couple clear setups in the movie that
give you some ideas about where the next
one might go they haven't made any
indications about when that movie's
gonna come or what the cast is gonna be
but I'll talk about that a little bit
more on spoilers because the ending does
give you a pretty good idea about how
they're gonna escalate the next movie so
I'm gonna talk about my favorite moments
from the film now so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet here
we go starting with number 5 dinosaurs
are starting to get boring the whole
starting point for the disaster in this
movie was the creation of the indominus
rex like you know the big villain of the
movie they created him because they felt
like people were getting bored with the
normal dinosaurs that's a big source of
comedy in the film there's a big joke
cuz Chris Pratt's like dinosaurs are
exciting enough by themselves why do you
need to make some crazy monster dinosaur
sponsored by Verizon no less that was
actually a great joke in the film
Verizon was actually a real life sponsor
of the film like they gave the Jurassic
world people a bunch of money so they'd
use their name in the film they said
they were totally fine with it with the
fact that the indominus rex kills a
bunch of people like they just like the
publicity so it's a joke in the film but
it's also a real-life product placement
thing this also gets into like the
subtext to the film you know what does
it say about us as people if we become
bored with something as crazy as
dinosaurs thematically they also tied
like the two young boys and with that
the older one is just only interested in
looking at girls like he absolutely
could care less about the dinosaurs in
the park
the consequence of that being is like
you know when you don't take dinosaurs
when you don't take these big things
seriously things go crazy that's what
Chris Pratt's character is shouting
through the entire movie he's like these
are real animals they don't care that
they were made in a test-tube all they
want to do is hunt eat and reproduce so
the big message of the film is respect
nature or face the consequences which
also kind of leads into what the sequels
probably gonna end up being on to number
four Henry Wu and Vincent d'Onofrio's
character create a genetic monster for
the military you could just tell the
minute someone said I'm not allowed to
tell you what DNA is inside this
dinosaur that it was going to turn out
to be like some crazy freakazoid
anytime someone in a film with holds
important information like that in a
crisis you kind of know that they're
gonna turn out to be the villain so if
you want to point to the real villains
of the film it's dr. Henry Wu and
Vincent D'Onofrio Vincent D'Onofrio is
actually an in ghent persons so
technically in Jenner the villains and
you could actually say that of all the
Jurassic Park films the only difference
between the geneticists in this film and
the other films are that the other films
they seemed a little bit more neutral
here he almost goes into maniacal
laughter when he's talking to omars I
he's the guy that plays the CEO the CEO
is like I'm shutting this down and Henry
was like you wouldn't have any of this
if it wasn't for me so very clearly the
villain in that situation let me know if
you figured out early on which dinosaurs
that big dinosaur was made of they gave
you a lot of clues with the footprint
and in the way it smelled it spray like
got up really close it's a giant summer
movie so it's made to be pretty easy to
follow so like you could take a little
kid to it and they should be able to
figure out what that giant dinosaur is
moving out to number three the indominus
rex is a t-rex Velociraptor hybrid there
was a lot of DNA from other animals in
there too like that's what the lab scene
was for them going through all the tanks
you know like the snake the lizard that
could change colors but the two big ones
were t-rex and Velociraptor so it was
you know really big and aggressive like
a t-rex but it was really smart and fast
like a Velociraptor the reason that they
created it is because Vincent D'Onofrio
was trying to sell a military contract
so they wanted to create this living
weapon so he went to the geneticist and
said I'll give you a ton of money if you
make this for me
that's why at the end of the film
whenever he was escaping whenever he was
flying off in the helicopter he took all
those embryos the important thing to
remember especially for the sequel is is
that he got off the island with those
embryos so they can make more indominus
rex --is on to number two Chris Pratt's
rapture pack this is one of the most fun
things about the film you take the
villain from the previous Jurassic Park
films and you make them your friends as
crazy as that seems they did to give
themselves like a back door with the
logic you know they're still very
vicious it's like trying to train giant
lions so Chris Pratt's character very
wisely says I don't control them it's a
relationship which is why you know
during the middle of the movie the
Raptors turn on them and follow a new
alpha pack mentality if you've ever
watched a werewolf movie you know
there's always an alpha and a beta
like there's a lot of that logic built
into the film if a new alpha comes along
that's more powerful the pack will
switch allegiance just think of the idea
of domesticated raptors though like so
domesticated they would put him in that
petting zoo but finally my number one
moment of the film t-rex vs indominus
rex this is an even better example of
turning the villain of the previous
movies into the hero of this film so as
much as the film puts Chris Pratt
forward is the hero of the film he's a
total badass the t-rex with a lot of
help from blue here in the aquatic
dinosaur are the big heroes of the film
really the biggest success of the film
is getting you to fall in love with that
velociraptor that helps the t-rex defeat
the indominus rex like he almost
sacrifices himself it's a very lassie
old yeller type moment so if you've ever
seen those movies have you ever seen Old
Yeller and you see the boys relationship
with the dog that's kind of like Chris
Pratt's relationship with the
velociraptors here's my big question for
you guys you know what was your favorite
moment from the film and did you love
those velociraptors by the end like do
you feel like the film was successful in
getting you to love them I feel like
anybody that's owned a dog or a large
pet will totally understand the
emotional roller coaster that the film
takes you on it does hit a lot of the
same beats the animal movies hit like
that
it's like Chris Pratt's Marley & Me
except instead of the dog it's a
velociraptor
there were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
in the film too though so let's talk
about a couple of the big ones first
Jake Johnson's t-shirt in case you
missed it the t-shirt that Jake Johnson
is wearing when you first meet him in
the film in that control room is the
logo from the original Jurassic Park
film there were a lot of moments where
the film was making fun of itself this
park is gonna be way better than the
original park you know giant air quotes
Jake Johnson's character himself is like
an alternate universe good version of
Wayne Knights character from the first
film in case you don't remember him he
was the guy that played Newman on
Seinfeld he was kind of like a dirtbag
in the first film Jake Johnson's
character is kind of like the schlub
like he is only he turns out to be a
hero in this film like I said this movie
takes a lot of the evil stuff from the
first couple of films flips it and makes
it good so philosoraptor t-rex Newman
all good in this film the other biggest
Easter eggs in the film though were when
the kids actually went to the original
park they opened the doors to what looks
like this Hidden Temple and they find
the main hall of the the original park
with like all those old cars
1993 Jeep Wrangler like they even say it
out loud this wasn't like a lot of small
Easter eggs to a lot of small visual
Easter eggs like the little cartoon from
the first film that explains DNA they
turned that into a hologram that was
playing in like that main room and the
one really awesome Bryce Dallas Howard
Easter Egg you knows when she she
grabbed the flare and released the t-rex
that was a nice homage to the first film
where Samuel used that flare to distract
the t-rex the only big criticism of the
film I've seen is the deus ex machina
and with the aquatic dinosaur getting
the indominus rex and you know pulling
it into the bay I felt like it totally
worked given that this movie isn't it to
be like a fun popcorn movie but you you
could argue that that kind of came out
of nowhere
but it's like trying to criticize a fast
and furious movie for twist in its logic
like it's not meant to portray reality
like this is pure fantasy but in case
you guys are watching this and you
haven't seen it yet be sure to go see it
it's a lot of fun they're definitely
going to be making more films next film
is probably going to follow up with the
doctor trying to make more indominus rex
'as in them getting loose all over the
world think about it this way the film
is called Jurassic world but you know
it's just a play on Disney World the
matically think about what that might
mean for the entire world if the
dinosaurs get out if the indominus rex
is get out unstoppable killing machines
loose all over the world I feel like
that's where the franchise is headed
it's a disaster movie franchise so why
not turn the island disaster into a
world disaster but you guys can let me
know you know where do you feel like the
sequel is going to go do you feel like
they're gonna make more of these and
they'll get loose all over the world
there are a couple other big movies that
are coming this summer in the next
couple of weeks including ant-man and
Fantastic Four I'll totally be doing
videos for them so so be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff if
there's any other movies that you guys
want me to do videos for just let me
know I'm trying to do more movie videos
while you guys wait for that in other
epic disasters this weekend The Game of
Thrones finale is coming up so you can
click here to learn all about the
night's king in the zora high and you
can click here to learn all about the
punisher coming to daredevil season 2
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight